venir au clos lucé cette entrée dans
l'univers de léonard de vinci découvrir
les machines qu'il a inventé le parc
qu'il a arpentée est la dernière demeure
qu'il a habité mais hier le passé s'est
invitée comme par magie le maître des
lieux a réapparu qui je suis je suis
allée ronald avg au commencement était
la musique omniprésente à la renaissance
souvent festives prélude de ses
flâneries organisé durant tout le
week-end
au programme des partitions d'époque et
des instruments d'autrefois viole de
gambe guiterne ou cornemuse
c'est carrément magique en fait parce
que cette musique là cette musique du
16e siècle
en fait pouvait se jouer à l'extérieur
musique et qui est fait pour s'amuser
aussi une musique est faite pour les
courtisans en fait elle apporte beaucoup
de plaisir aux gens
la nuit tombe léonard de vinci s'apprête
à monter sur scène le public déambule
librement dans le parc
c'est la toute première fois qu'il peut
s'y promener le soir et se faire
surprendre au gré de ses alliés
fut demandé comment il se fait que
françois 1er a eu l'idée de me commander
des fêtes
au total trois saynètes qui évoque la
vie du grand homme mais interprétés par
une femme
la guerre est arrivée être dans la peau
de léonard de vinci c'est extraordinaire
c'est inouï je n'aurais même pas
imaginer parce que la simple pot c'est
déjà quelque chose mais être chez lui en
plus à gaza soit dans son domaine
solaire merci merci beaucoup
la création est très très belle c'est
fabuleux c'est plein de rêves c'est
extraordinaire sept hectares entièrement
illuminé jusqu'à près de minuit un
univers presque irréelle où l'on
s'attend croiser des elfes et des faits
hier soir 600 personnes sont venus
flâner au clos lucé d'autres reviendront
pourquoi pas l'été prochain
[Musique]